é para tanta gente meu deus do céu é lá
muito votar é tão bom senso e botar
haitham mais uma vez boa tarde como é
que tudo vai rolar e tags o reclamante
poste antes de mais quero te agradecer
por terem vindo e que agradeço a vocês
próprios o facto de terem
disponibilizado está aqui comigo conosco
com historiadores com nossas próprias
numa diz se inspirar em e se motivarem
desde a agradeço em meu nome e no do
santos tem 27 anos e vani contará um
pouco da minha história
como podem ver ler eu sou apologista
visto
acho que todos nós temos esta capacidade
a música não há mas agora quero
perguntar se alguma vez sentir um pedido
quem é que está a vitória já sentiu uma
ligeira noção do que não sabia quem era
por um dia e o canal a equipe jesus qual
99.850 boas notícias mas não tem esses
vão ver com as duas
eu acredito que são precisas mas é que
isto vai continuar a acontecer cocaína
nós vamos sentir que de vez em quando
vamos sentir os projetos não sabemos
quem somos
devido a algumas circunstâncias as
coisas nossas e vamos atingir alguns
bairros sem se sentir falhado
a boa notícia é que é muito importante
que isso aconteça e que vocês não
descartem esse acontecimento o facto de
nós nos sentimos perdidos vai nos
obrigar a sair da zona de conforto e
procurar novos caminhos novas direções
em hotel dezesseis anos era um rapaz
muito ativo
fazem muito desporto federado e raízes
várias áreas fiz um bom tênis
bakkour bordo fazia tudo para botas
e é tão clinton está agora a entrar com
o pé direito e missa
o catar
[Aplausos]
eu tenho 36 anos era muito saudável
fazia estava sempre à procura de
aventuras de adrenalina
minha filha base a experiência eo cria
uma seda de vida o desejo de nos sentir
vivo procurava tudo aquilo que fosse o
limite anual de porto de fora leu e com
poder lê já era um rapaz de 12 anos
depois passei a ser um rapaz de todos o
mais careca aos 10 anos e não
diagnosticado um cancro um tumor ósseo
muito agressivo
já como taz tipo nariz em coisas
horríveis e um violino
assim o rio foi um detalhe 16 anos que
não sabiam se eu ia conseguir sobreviver
ou não
no entanto não tentar de tudo e não
fazer o protocolo ao todo estarão
inclusive que eu não queria que ninguém
morreu
ismar ese jornada quer ser de vida
estava em mim e entrou por um ouvido e
saiu pelo outro e não sentir o inter
sente bem
apesar de lutar com o meu rendimento
tanto na escola como na vida já não era
o que era ali no fim dos 15 a um
episódio que disputa
nildo bem estar eu levantei praia grande
no dia de são martinho em 2007 como
melhor amigo de infância e então
imaginar o mar de inverno na praia
grande na própria mental o confortável é
doido
já no já no verão s regressiva e eu né
nem consciência da urgência que requer
boa idéia ir apanhar ondas
agora é assim que eu cheguei à praia
havia mais surfistas investidos na área
do que na água devia ter sido muito
respeitáveis sinal
eu achei que não foi 30 quilômetros
entrei na água
a máquina de lavar é um querido deputado
gionvanni 200 série que ainda para
embrulhar chato por uma pela pressa de
contas à vida lhe baixo entre fazer nada
portanto fiquei a pensar nas coisas que
fazer com que essa casa quando viu de
cima sem ter nunca tinha voado de
penteado inclusive e sair da água com
cher
desde então foram exames exames anos
ninguém desconfiava de nada
achavam que era de coluna daqui o
impacto e pronto quando diagnosticam um
cancro ou se um sarcoma do ing
esta foi a probabilidade de
sobrevivência disseram num 3 5 por cento
na melhor das hipóteses nós não podemos
fazer promessas
vamos tentar tudo
e percebi altura era mais jovem
percebi algo que era tas tramava
provavelmente contrárias a essa festa
não é fácil
coisa que hoje não acredito que hoje em
dia se me dissessem que o rio porque
sentiu certo qual é a escala visto você
for ver afinal somos bons a sobreviver
numa sessão em que o número vai cair e
hoje acredito que todos nós mas
porcentagens cruz nem qualquer área da
nossa vida nós somos criadores da nossa
realidade pode mudar 03 capaz é
impossível então observa 15 minutos mas
você não cria um cento de probabilidade
do que seja
fiz muitos tratamentos aquela coisa
horrível
julinho por favor diga trip
o transplante é uma coisa horrível de
ficar e 30 dias dentro de um aquário
fiquei num aquário branco 35 de 30
quilos eu sei que é um sonho para muita
gente não quer
felizmente não porque não come durante
três semanas durante três semanas em que
a boca
acho que a marca sangrar enfim é tão
bonita
fiz uma cirurgia para remover é única
porque era lá onde estava alojado o
tumor e eles era moreno vai poder ser o
prazo
uma das armas para o cancro pode ser
usado em que a cirurgia é e tão bom e em
que consiste a perder a mobilidade
então não sei se não gosto acho que não
cabe a ele vai perceber que não gosto
dessa hipótese
no entanto esse programa deve estar vivo
que isto está vivo gestão prótese também
interessa a ninguém mas é um evento
particular no a mãe da quimioterapia não
esqueça levantar numa tarde foram
exatamente no final de junho estava em
pior lisboa
minha mãe e minha irmã foram as atrizes
buscar uma pisa porque acreditamos que
teremos ao menos um rifle
trouxeram uma pisa e antes disso eu
fiquei meia hora no máximo porque ela
tinha encomendado por meia hora no
máximo sozinho no quarto do hospital eo
primeiro cêntimo das tramava capaz de
morrer
começa a sentir um fogo madrid na urina
vinda não sei do ano
o tac para que hoje em dia eu sair a lei
tanto de um soco na empresa então pressa
vai tão depressa foi desapareceu eo ie
caiu a ficha de uma fase que não definem
nada é transitório e que para mudar de
estratégia precisa mudar a minha vida
toda com base em algumas coisas que foi
mudar a minha cabecinha a maneira como
eu pensava era pessimista é o pior
inimigo quantas vezes não votava com
coisas que eu queria fazer o mesmo e
sair com a opinião dos outros
mudei minha alimentação
eu sei que é muito melhor continuei
treinando aí está muito limitado na
altura tinha 12 m com dores coutinho e
no momento em que estava e fiz muito
humor como deixa de um sarcoma sarcoma e
lembro de morfina durante
aproximadamente um ano
já ouvi alguém agência e então eu lembro
da minha mãe muito preocupada com
qualquer amarra obviamente ela tentava
mexer com nível logo abaixo
fica forte e exercer
airton bom novo nenhum enfermeiro e um
médico não tivesse praxado desde comprar
sair os falsos no carnaval etapa para me
dizer uma dor no peito
não vamos ver vamos escutar e lembra de
deus usarem os auscultadores desabituar
em fazer aquela cara de sp que estava
acamada estava vivo eu tenho em mim e
num nome estar a bater no entanto por
mais estratégias que eu tivesse
continuado mas sente perdido continuava
a sentir muito em baixo porque aquela
perna já tinha gasto dos recursos
emocionais físicos psicológicos e
financeiros possíveis e imaginárias
eu estava super primeiro e pensamentos
suicidas durante muito tempo faz parte
até que comecei a pensar até que ponto é
que eu preciso dessa pena até que ponto
é que tem que aguentar isto estas dores
tudo isso que estou a viver porque eu
tenho que aguentar isso porque o bairro
e se há alguma cirurgia mais pra frente
que não salva a perna
esse algo mais para frente que eu
consigo fazer se no fim da linha
somos uma coisa
queremos também mas decidi vir ninguém
disse ninguém sugeriu ninguém mais
conseguiu
eu lembro que no fim do ano 2014 foi o
pior ano já tenha vencido a partida
antológica mas a pena gastar
não não não dava disse eu pensei vou ter
a pena eu tenho mais dois braços e tenho
uma perna só então foi às vezes teria
mais baratas porque não interessa pela
foram dois anos de preparação não foi
nada fácil imagine o que é que há
o cinema está fechado ela vai ter uma
pergunta não é uma decisão do pé para a
mão
[Risadas]
a mãe tinha que ser feito e que ser
feito é mesmo com algum mesmo
naturalmente não estava tão indeciso mas
lembro que no dia em que cheguei ao
hospital eu tava os punhos
eu sei a filmar e tudo está tudo na net
lancei com as enfermeiras eu reuni com
os médicos
eu estava mais feliz do que nunca porque
sabia que finalmente o meu instrumento e
acabar eu ia deixar viver em função de
uma perna a viver em função de mim mais
perdido que eu tenha dado faz parte hoje
em dia já aceito sair faz parte do
processo
eu encontrei na minha decisão muita
queda muito eu fui contra muitas paredes
nos encontramos porque teve de decidir
andar na maré
eu acredito que é isso que nós devemos
fazer para que nós possamos sentir falta
não é desculpa todos nós sentimos todos
nós pensamos todos nós temos uma
intuição zinha alguém fala conosco ele
quer que seja que o que for na vossa
vida é que o que for que nos impeça de
ver o vosso potencial de vir aqui o que
é bom pra vocês seja uma pessoa seja um
vício um hábito trabalho uma ação tóxica
conforme aquilo que os prendem que vos
atrás que não faça viver aquilo que é
bom pra vocês façam uma e só uma coisa
que é cortar o mal pela raiz
é só nisso que eu acredito que todos nós
temos esse potencial escolha nossa não é
porque aconteceu isto que aconteceu aqui
o clube londrino está no campo não tem
tudo tudo tudo é decidir encontrar o
nosso caminho
não esqueçam disso obrigado
[Aplausos]